[Música]
luis arts se cumple su primer año como
presidente de bolivia con protestas en
medio de una crisis económica y también
social ar se asumió la presidencia el 8
de noviembre del año pasado 2020 tras
vencer en las urnas con el movimiento al
socialismo más con el 55.1 por ciento de
apoyo tras la grave crisis 2019 causada
por la renuncia de evo morales justo
ayer inició un paro indefinido que
terminó con más de un centenar de
detenidos y varios heridos la huelga
general es el rechazo a la llamada ley
madre del gobierno que busca luchar
contra la legitimación de las ganancias
ilícitas y el financiamiento al
terrorismo en las regiones de santa cruz
santa cruz-cochabamba la paz tarija
potosí oruro y beni se sintieron más los
bloqueados y también las protestas que
terminaron como ya lo dijimos con
decenas de detenidos los enfrentamientos
entre los que bloquean las vías y la
policía y grupos que intentaban disparar
las protestas marcaron esta primera
jornada de paro indefinido en bolivia
por eso entonces quiero darle la
bienvenida a nuestro primer imitables
eduardo córdoba politólogo y sociólogo
analista político eduardo gracias por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 por supuesto empezamos con el
balance de este año del usarse y le
pregunto que se puede destacar tanto lo
bueno como lo malo
muchas gracias raúl gracias por la
invitación y saludos a todos los que
están
conectados a las 24 en primer lugar debe
señalarse que el gobierno de arse entró
con varias ofertas explícitas e
implícitas una de las ofertas más
explícitas era solucionar la crisis
política o traer a enfrentar la crisis
económica y otra era enfrentar la crisis
generada por la pandemia y la crisis
sanitario en sus ofertas menos menos
explícitas estaba recuperar la confianza
en las instituciones cosa que es una es
muy complicado siempre en bolivia porque
somos uno de los países más desconfiados
no solamente en las relaciones
interpersonales sino también frente a
las
instituciones y también cumplir otras
ofertas menos menos explícitas
relacionadas con las bases sociales del
movimiento socialismo es decir la
distribución
también distribución de tierras que es
un problema muy muy muy fuerte
en el tratamiento de la pandemia hay una
cosa muy diferente de la integración con
el gobierno anterior porque han llegado
las vacunas y ha habido un impulso
digamos aunque el discurso de ayer del
presidente no no se puede entender muy
bien en cuanto a las cifras por porque
hay un problema de información de su
registro y también de de manejo
institucional
de los datos
sí ahí sí hay si se ha avanzado si se ha
enfrentado también con varios problemas
como el negacionismo en algunos casos
ese es un elemento en cuestiones
económicas
si hay un rebote si hay un rebote
notable de una disminución del 12% o
algo más en el pib el año pasado a un
aumento del nuevo president oria algo
más en este año ese es un efecto muy muy
importante aunque hay que ver todavía si
eso es sostenible
mejores precios de las materias primas
que exporta bolilla pero la
productividad y el aparato productivo
mismo no sabemos si pueden soportar eso
hacia más adelante
y en cuanto a la crisis política
persiste la polarización la crisis
política no es solamente el conflicto
entre el más y la oposición sino también
una crisis institucional muy fuerte
donde la confianza es importante y lo
señale un elemento clave de esta crisis
es la dificultad de la justicia de
enfrentarlas los problemas que se están
presentando
y otro caso es
que hay un desajuste entre en la misma
cultura política 30 las necesidades es
decir hay bastante improvisación y ahí
con dificultades también en este caso de
enfrentar los problemas ahora si el
balance del primer año es que se ha
mejorado económicamente sigue eso es
indudable la la pandemia está
enfrentándose pero la crisis política
persiste y de verdad que en bolivia no
se puede decir a dónde pueden llegar los
los problemas y es que hay varios
problemas en la mesa pero primero vamos
a pensar hablando de la posición qué va
a pasar con el grupo opositor y también
la situación específica de la que fue
presidenta interina de bolivia
jeanine áñez que recordemos se encuentra
detenida a eduardo
y a la oposición hay diferentes grupos
de oposición también eso es algo que hay
que hay que notar no es una oposición
dura y robusta y sólida y unánime frente
al frente al movimiento al socialismo lo
que están intentando hacer algunos
grupos es unificar la oposición
y una manera de hacerlo es generar los
movimientos como los que están
sucediendo ahora hay una posición más
más radical digamos y hay una posición
más moderada en la oposición radical
están grupos que
generaron la violencia
en el año 2019
y en la oposición más moderada grupos
que salieron a las calles a protestar
sin
intención digamos de claro de golpe de
estado de lo que se ha hablado después
entonces la oposición está en
en esa idea esa idea diversa de oponerse
al gobierno y hay quienes están en
el partido de oposición que están
tratando de impulsar cambios en las
políticas públicas y hay quienes están
de hecho intentando
oponerse y hasta en el extremo
perjudicar las
políticas si lo que lo que sucede con
giannina es que ha sido tomado ese
gobierno por algunas partes de la
oposición y también por el más como un
pretexto es decir ayer en el discurso
del presidente darse todo era una
comparación con lo que había sucedido el
año anterior durante el gobierno de
animales y parte de la oposición también
critica el gobierno de ella ni menos
porque fue represivo hay ejecuciones
extrajudiciales ahí hay hubo dos
masacres que no se pueden esconder pero
en su momento apoyaron también hizo
eduardo ese gobierno si te quiero
interrumpir un momento por favor para
hacer la casi la última pregunta esta
conversación porque pues evidentemente
el dinero nos alcanza para hacer un
balance completo de lo que fue este año
pero qué podemos esperar lo que queda de
mandato deslizarse tenemos como 40
segundos para responder esta pregunta si
se puede
y
es ni complicado ya se sabe que en
bolivia no se puede predecir no se puede
calcular lo que sí se puede saber es que
va a haber necesidad de más acuerdos
políticos y de fomentar algo que durante
el gobierno de evo morales y en este
primer año del gobierno de dejarse no no
no hubo que es una idea de
crear articulación es crear hegemonía
desde el mismo paso también desde la
oposición porque hasta ahorita las
posiciones han encontrado no se está
tratando de escuchar mucho a los
nosotros entonces si es que no cambia
eso es posible que tengamos conflictos
periódicos como el que se está dando
ahora a lo largo de los próximos años